c'est vrai on va faire est laid
chirurgie une très bonne nouvelle on va
pouvoir faire un point sur les scores à
à un point sur les scores les chéris
avant d'avoir le duel de jean luc jean
luc lemoine spécialiste fléchettes les
cherry est ce qu'on peut avoir les
points et je vous le dis les points qui
seront affichés c'est les points on ne
discute pas d'accord d'accord on en a
assez des discussions sans cesse
d'accord attention ça va les gars là si
vous êtes super à l'aise du fait de
votre vie vous êtes formidable on bosse
à 2 heures du matin vous êtes géniaux
mois merci jean michel mr 20 points
c'est le seul mint abba non mon mari n'a
pas ce que c'est je viens de remarquer
classement en fait c est mettre les
poings et non se démerdent peut-être
vous mais les points on peut pas tout
faire
ledit de on peut pas compter en plus
d'amasser les mecs non mais alors jeté
un gobelet alors matthieu delormeau 25
25 points j'ai en tête
yahoo ces papous des noms mais c'est
bizarre ça thierry l'on ne discute pas
une fois surtout à noël et marie alors
mokhtar 15 points jean-luc 15 points
isabelle 15 points thierry 15 - tout
cela sont susceptibles pour le moment
avec sébastien qui a dix points
non non sébastien cauet ils sont
susceptibles d'être réveil je vous lis
il ne reste plus qu'une épreuve
cette épreuve c'est l'épreuve
d'aujourd'hui vous le savez je ne
voulait jamais caché jean luc et mon
petit préféré c'est mon ami ça fait 25
ans qu'on se connaît on s'est connus sur
le mékong
c'était rigolo mais avec le rire
d'autres crétins
c'est jean-luc vous à venir me rejoindre
et cette épreuve va compter pour 30
points on va falloir un oui c'est le
super cadeau bonus attention jean-luc
comment ça va mon chéri ça va bien mais
ça veut dire quoi je gagne 30 points
aussi où je perds trompe pas vous vous
je verrai après vous inquiétez pas vous
avez un ami
[Rires]
non ça n'a rien à voir avec ce que vous
croyez les règles seront droite et je
peux vous dire qu'il n'y aura pas deux
attention jean-luc on le sait vous visez
toujours juste dans cette émission dans
la vie privée je ne sais pas mais je
sais pas moi de le dicrim laon bat un ge
va tester votre capacité à taper dans le
mille
d'accord mais alors qu'il paraît que les
fléchettes les fléchettes c'est votre
hobby ça fait partie de mes hobbies vous
adorez les fléchettes pour qu'elle se
disait beaucoup de ce hobby pas que vous
êtes très déco pendant des années il ya
des couacs retrait des noms vous êtes
une traînée de la nature est depuis des
années j'ai vraiment 2 heures du matin
vous vous êtes entraîné vraiment pour
cette épreuve
exactement alors je vous dis jean-luc
nous allait être confronté à philippe il
est champion dans sa catégorie
il fait partie de l'équipe de france
giuly c'est un peu le griezmann de la
fléchette as well as well as je voulais
c'est un patron le gars ça veut dire
desquesnes fléchettes boeuf on la prend
ici là et ouais les gars regardez c'est
le dernier duel de la soirée
et c'est là que ça va se jouer c'est
parti
[Musique]
je passerai
non
à l'écouter
jean-luc s'affilie pour m'accueillir si
on suit le champion de fléchettes
philippe philippe cayla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh alors bonjour salué philippe seuls
les livres c'est un champion de
fléchettes philippe sertic ont
maintenant fait de la fléchette ross a
fait une bonne dizaine d'années
maintenant d'accord comment comment
parce que champion de fléchettes c'est
commencer partie de ses parts dans un
bain et en fait après il ya les
championnats qui se déroule dans chaque
région et on se retrouve tous à la
rochelle pour disputer le titre champion
de france en équipes en doublettes sur
trois
alors j'ai été champion de france en
2011 vice champion 2010 et vice-champion
[Musique]
12h07 et jean-luc alors je vous dis bien
sûr il va vous allez avoir un handicap
c'est bien normal c'est très simple
philippe est ce que vous voulez nous
faire juste petites tenues d'une petite
démo pour voir comme ça de quoi vous
êtes grave
donc voilà juste pour voir pour vous
montrer un petit peu le niveau du gard
voilà regarder on se met là c'est juste
derrière l' attention attention tu perds
ton slip a loupé la fait gaffe quand
même voix dans le mille
o dans la ville attendez vous à le
mecque ohlala pas dégueu
c'est son métier 1
on voit le gars voilà certes
impressionnant mais il va pas tirer
comme ça vous en doutez bien vous allez
jouer dos à la cible doit la cible et
vous allez avoir un miroir et donc il va
tirer comme ça qui va faire le plus de
points jean luc lemoine en normal ou
notre champion philippe riou à la cible
gens alors pendant que vous votez vous
réfléchissez y ont fait une petite comme
ça pour le clip ainsi l'attention je me
mets bien la rage mais tu peux voir pas
mal 19 19
ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est pas c'est
pas de 17 x 3 je me tue pas ses 17 x 300
vrai wayne est vrai et ça c'est pas si
mal
alors alors chroniqueur chroniqueur
champions champions s'empilent
chroniqueur chroniqueur chroniqueur
chroniqueur champion kohei attention
vous êtes le dernier pour la dre bah oui
réfléchissez bien
ouais bah oui je sais mais une pression
on peut être sûr vous misez sur jean-luc
non bah je suis sûr que dans je suis
plus sûr de rien ça fait plaisir en tout
cas et si je pense qu'il va s'en sortir
vachement bien avec la glace c'est
dangereux c'est plus facile alors
attention vous allez tirer chacun votre
tour 3 fait chic de londres à hachette
oui bah oui 3 fléchettes c'est comme ça
que ça se passe on est en compétition
internationale
on va démarrer par philippe clip vous
allez démarrer vous dirait une pêche
chacun votre tour d'accord comme ça ça
va être un petit peu plus de suspense et
la dernière épreuve de la soirée
on va savoir qui va gagner et qui va
gagner son ticket et son billet pour le
style et on partira le 16 décembre et
toute l'équipe avec ceux qui seront
qualifiés et on sera tous ceux qui
pendant quatre jours les cherry et vous
verrez tout ça bien sûr touche pas à mon
poste au ski ce sera un prime en jambes
attention philippe mais philippe tu te
fous de ma gueule
atteint de dos
alors qu'ils me changent jamais à banon
mais changent pas alors moi je change
pas compris comment il fait vraiment
très moi pour mon affaire voilà
maintenant je change pas allez on y va
allez c'est parti
je citais mieux
[Musique]
ouais pas mal première s'affaireront ça
on sent les gens lui alors là c'est
parce qu'on joue sur la carte aurait
autant pour moi mais moi je n'ai rien à
la tunisienne
oui combien combien ces gens lui fallait
gagner la 35è là quand ça aura 52 c'est
faisable
tu peux y arriver jean luc viaux légal
peut y arriver j'ai pas d'âme il ya 52 à
battre mon jean luc
à tangi jean-luc libre avec l'apce 17
web on est malheureusement à 37 c'est
perdu pour jean-luc pièce matin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait robert en fait j'ai cru l'endroit
abandonné bravo quand même pas les frais
je suis très déçu oui bah oui on est
tous très déçus et on va faire un point
les scores et j'aimerais que
l'ordinateur se met en marche
on va savoir qui a gagné son ticket pour
le ski je crois qu'un art c'est sa
première saison
mais je crois qu'il va déjà partir au
ski avec lui
on va voir qui sont les premiers je
crois qu'il ya des égalités
attention nous sommes en direct je vous
rappelle à l échelle on va me passer les
deux heures du matin ça fait lens
10h10 heure on est en direct avec vous
et ça continue dans la soirée vous
pouvez nous appeler pendant la nuit là
encore pendant une heure une heure et
quart et on va pouvoir gérer plein de
problèmes si vous avez des soucis de
placer 12 heures chez nous ça fait tout
ça oui ça fait douze mille euros je suis
alors les chéris avant de voir les
scores et avant de voir qu'est le
dernier et qui est le premier
sachez qu'il ya le grand jeu un des 35
heures de barre à plus de 20000 euros de
cadeaux à gagner plein de cadeaux et
surtout de magnifiques week-end dans un
célèbre casinos et hôtels en france
la question est simple répondre à la
question quels fruits olga qui étaient
avec nous tout à l'heure à t-elle écrasé
entre ses cuisses des pastèques ou des
cerises attention il ya peut-être un
piège donc fait il ya quand même
quelqu'un dans public est persuadé
d'avoir la bonne réponse kikito des
cerises
voilà merci alors attention déchiré
voici les scores les scop c'est parti
benjamin castaldi l'a gagné
tanguay moi non un peu le mot à mot
bazana edadi n'avait pas songé à changer
mais l'ordinateur à des primo premier
truc alors je ne dis pas les passants
rien dit de ce nom n'était pas avec lui
devant l'épreuve
je viens de gagner cette épreuve en
cavale aussi pareil bah voila en gros si
ya un non ça va des mécanismes bizarre
il sa change pas que ce soit le cas dans
l'ue doivent aussi là je suis à 38 l'ag
champions ouais il a changé les visages
aussi annonce avait changé oui non mais
non s'il autorise et a dit non je ne
pouvais pas en fait parce que
l'ordinateur empereur à oui on pourrait
récupérer gill qui a changé aussi
sincères makhachkala russia mots ma
question où est fallacieuse le toit les
chérir on va s'occuper du dernier dans
un instant benjamin est ce que vous
pourrez partir avec nous le 16 décembre
au ski c'est bien sûr non c'est vrai
j'ai rien dit a vu encore donc je pense
que oui pourrait ramener
voilà oui mais c'est parce que je ne
partirai pas oui alors c'est alors non
mais son conjoint jamais que je vienne
et nous dise plus que vous toucherez que
des boules de neige
[Rires]
et oui donc benjamin castaldi s'allier
il part au ski il sera avec nous le 16
décembre le dernier on l'a vu c'est
cauet cauet mon chéri je sais que tu as
la radio le soir je vais je sais que je
t'aime beaucoup ça fait des années qu'on
est comme ça eh bien oui d'autant la
saloperie non pas nouveau je vais te
demander une petite chose je sais que tu
pourras pas rester toute la nuit avec
moi j'ai des enfants
il a des enfants mais oui il a des
droits mais juste pour le kiff
à est ce que tu peux juste rentré dans
le réveil et dire au revoir pour cette
émission et qu'on se retrouve dans un
instant pour la suite du programme des
35 heures c'est avec plaisir croît fait
tout de suite je suis un ami je le fais
où je fais là et je rentre en réveil
quoi vous préférez quoi il est entré en
ruine ont préféré une autre série qui
revient mais on y arrive à se mettre en
règle revient dans un instant j'espère
qu'il a effacé le golfeur à nos côtés
sachez qu'on va se retrouver dans un
instant puisque je retourne à l'ancien
studio un de ses huit tout de suite pour
vous prendre au téléphone
il va y avoir des jeux on va se régaler
ya jean michel maire qui reste avec moi
y'a caroline ithurbide qui sera avec
nous qui veut venir un tome on peut
venir voilà je vous le dis je suis j'ai
piscine a maintenant à la merci des
rescapés avec nous comment venir des
cylons râler vous reposez vous les
chéris parce que de maria une grosse
journée
je vous dis j'ai l'impression d'être
l'animateur vous savez de quoi demain
les chiffres il ya une grosse journée
puisque on démarrera demain matin à 6
heures du matin avec camille combal
on fera les missionnaires direct sur ces
vies de 6h à 10h l'émission radio qui
sera rediffusée sur s'est vite on sera
vraiment au direct de ses 8 10 heures il
y aura une émission touche pas à verser
à la perche et aux faux
voilà alors que les fouilles qui va
durant voire dans l'instant tu sais
chérie à partir de 10 heures et les
shows spéciale avec de la gym avec avec
la cuisine avec thierry moreau qui sera
avec moi ils abordèrent de tout ceci
montre à une recette tout ça ce sera
jusqu'à 12h à peu près en suisse le pré
l'édition spéciale à la place de daphné
burki voilà des sujets et larmes à
l'édition spéciale à 100 parce que je
vous dis ceux qui aiment le tennis vous
sera les coûts ce qui aimait bien le
tennis club sur france 4
aussi il y aura plein de choses on
parlera également de kim kardashian dans
un flic qui nous donnera des infos sur
toute cette affaire les shirin et il y
aura ensuite le touche pas mon après
midi avec valérie benaïm touche pas à
mon poste
la quotidienne de demain soir avec une
surprise puisqu'on jouera aux amours
avec certains conjoints
voilà deux des membres de l'équipe qui
ont joué aux amours avec nous derrière
il y aura donc touche pas à mon poste la
folle histoire avec tout le monde
en direct les chéris on verra surtout
les moments et vous verrez lire aussi
les trucs de fou et juste après il y
aura les interdits durant les quatre
tiers de jean luc lemoine demain soir en
prime des quatre pierre curzi et on suit
pas demain à 2 heures du matin il nous
reste donc nous reste l'autre 24 heures
24 heures d'émission les séries on se
repose depuis leurs services en direct
que ça
si les 35 heures de là pourquoi ne pas
venir
[Applaudissements]
n oubliez pas l'atletico
tout ça sans qu'il en ait pas mieux avec
talent à tous
il reste trois minutes
nicolas d'alexis tassement l'action
venir on va pas faire long feu
sony blond va faire qu'on a on va
vraiment faire joli on va faire quoi
sert winner max 1h max si la définition
d'un truc c'est énorme
l'équipe est folle je vais boire voix et
vidéo le médecin il et il me donne une
pastille ouais ça va mais chéri va bien
toi nathan formons pas sympa ici les
deux heures du matin trois qui je suis
pas sûr ouais ouais ouais j'suis pas sûr
on va on va pas faire longtemps on va
faire une heure avec l'autre n'est pas
fatigué mon chéri non ça va taito repose
après puisque tu vas bien et je dors ou
en fait la part un petit lit là non mais
c'est bien là moi je pensais bien là sur
le canapé alors venez faire des grattons
les cheveux comme ça pas mal je suis
bien là
comment on est dans quel ordre
son pression va pas faire longtemps
non on va faire un beau la vie on va
faire une heure max mais il ya ce sera
la seule je vous dis oui les chéris jeu
ni magie on perd la mémoire au fond d'un
regarde l'histoire d'un soir une image
ici
merci d'être avec nous les chars et on
continue les 35 heures qu'il est
exactement 2h25
et on ne vous lâche pas un sur twitter
continuer mes chéris hashtag des 35
heures de baba les seydoux des messages
espère vous êtes encore nombreux à nous
regarder caroline ithurbide est avec moi
ça va ma carte à lui à la manne allait
me salue claude alexis le voyant qu'on
aime beaucoup je vais vous mettre dans
toutes mes émissions il est beau gentil
merci à vous faire plaisir et roselyne
est avec toi leur usine c'est une jeune
fille qu'on a découvert et vous êtes
quoi vous êtes chez naturopathe
naturopathe à dire qu'elle adore la
nature et elle adore les psychopathes et
donc leur patois la voilà il ya une très
bonne base producteurs qui me dit elle
mange des pâtes nature c'est c'est très
sympa très bas mais j'aurai l'occasion
de me présenter peut-être les y
passerait bien de vous la naturopathie
en fait c'est la médecine d'autres
médecines naturelles occidentales comme
l'arrivée d'ares en inde où la médecine
chinoise en chine
et voilà il est un format là ils étaient
23 que c'est surtout la soeur de
géraldine maillet merci alors vous allez
pouvoir nous a plu ce soir il ya jean
michel maire qui va venir nous rejoindre
également et je vous le dis toutes les
heures on offre 1000 euros à
l'association c'est que du bonheur pour
l'instant on est à exactement douze
mille euros a pour cette association
présidée par hélène si cette association
d'eau qui déploie toute son énergie pour
améliorer la qualité de vie des enfants
hospitalisés merci des cherry on a le
pauline qui est avec nous ça lupopo
pauline est ce qu'elle est là déjà
pauline d'accord merci
on est en train de l'appeler pauline je
vous cache pas alors là on va faire une
petite heure d'émission tranquille à 30
tirs de près ou à peu près dans une
petite quarantaine de minutes des
versions et après tranquille après bas
ceux qui veulent rester peuvent rester
moi je vais m'allonger un peu sur le
canapé je vais dormir un peu à taiwan
nan mais c'est le droit de dormir mais
je suis toujours à l'antenne je suis à
l'antenne pendant voilà donc pendant
deux heures je serai à l'antenne voilà
en train de dormir après je fais la
matinale de camille combal
donc on fait la matinale avec camille a
ensuité bon on va voir notre mère et
puis voilà quoi
et attend les enquêtes en ligne qui est
en ligne
c'est vrai que robin salle urbain
comment ça va mon chéri ça va mon chéri
pour l'instant 12 heures ça se passe
super bien
tu es content le dépens de cinq heures
tu t'es avec nous depuis le début non
c'est pas vrai vos séries telles que
c'est incroyable ça va tu kiffes ouais
franchement je kiffe et en plus tu viens
demain soir et ça va être la folie match
et rien je te le dit de m'asseoir et
voient en effet leur année puis derrière
il ya les interdits et il y aura du 4/3
de jean luc lemoine vont en prendre
plein la gueule comment ça va robin
alors ses patates richmond série donc tu
m'appelles dis moi pourquoi tu
m'appelles dis moi pourquoi tu nous
appelles on a on peut tout faire pour
toi et ben écoute moi je t'appelle juste
pour pour prendre des nouvelles de toi
ça va vraiment bien et puis et je veux
surtout savoir la privation de sommeil
sur quoi un peu si tu commences à avoir
des phases d'irritabilité du commentaire
à avoir envie des lotois aussi parce que
je ne sais et je ne suis pas allé aux
toilettes de la journée j'ai fait du
bien je te cache pas que j'ai fait j'ai
fait trois fois puis je voulais tant
parler mais je n'ai pas fait popo pas du
tout je suis sur un autre délire total
quoi je trouve ça ringard tout le monde
le fait vraiment c'est un truc avec
lequel j'ai complètement décroché pour
l'instant je suis pas du tout y est
irritable
maintenant je suis bien dans ma tête ça
fait douze heures de direct 12h30 match
en direct
alors on se tourne vers notre
naturopathe qu'est ce que je risque
qu'est-ce que tu risques d'avoir bas de
la grosse fatigue une dette de sommeil
qui va s'accumuler à te serais voila
voila on pendant plusieurs jours donc
moi ce que je peux te proposait déjà
dans un premier temps c'est demain
d'aller de coucher à peu près à 1h
convenable non mais dommage je continue
jusqu'à 2 ouais je sais je serai donc
dès que tu as fini à 2 heures du matin
si tu peux te coucher ça serait cool
d'accord ne part enchaîner avec encore
une deuxième
nuit complète de
et puis et puis le lendemain mettre le
réveil à une heure à peu près des
centres pour pas décaler ton cycle 2 1
d'accord voilà le genre il faut pas
décalé ça qu'elle était khaleq al qadi
quitté calais catane aux éau et robin
sinon tu fais quoi tu as peut-être tu
fais quoi dans la vie mon chéri et ben
écoute moi je t'appelle de tourcoing et
je suis animateur d'émissions de cuisine
tu auras permettre non c'est en gros
c'est quoi ton si bon boulot on a eu il
ya plusieurs sites je suis prestataires
donc que je bosse pour un site qui
s'appelle cuisineaz et pour un autre
site qui s'appelle my mag est en fait je
suis je connais on connait on my mind
donc eh ben voilà c'est quoi ta
spécialité
eh ben je sais tout je fais toutes les
recettes préférées des français donc
tout ce qui est conviviale tous la bonne
grosse tartiflette au pam il ajouté tout
ce que les la flammekueche exactement
pourquoi moi mon plat préféré bras ouais
alors c'est les pédales arrabiata mais
parce que j'adore les penne que je suis
un petit peu arables donc voilà je mange
souvent des pédales arabia table je suis
je suis moitié moitié je suis mi figue
mi raisin
donc voilà donc je vois là donc je sais
tu sais les faire ou pas non je n'en a
rien à [ __ ] de ramener un petit truc
demain soir ce sera plutôt web
eh ben je serai au chocolat un petit
gâteau chocolat matin amour et batanes
amour je t'embrasse très fort mais robin
tu restes avec nous encore la pause
nuire bon courage
allez je t'embrasse mon chéri je
t'embrasse fort je t'embrasse très fort
et les bat on a on a un garçon qu'est
que c'est kevin qu'on va voir par skype
les chéris va regarder je le vois
qu'elle visait la vie n'est pas mal est
beau gosse québec et j'ai tout est pas
mal vieux petit cul l'a1 est ce qu'on
entend bien tout en contentant te vois
on aime la vie comment fabriquer vinh et
ben ça va très très bien et boue et toi
surtout comment ça se passe pour toi
bats je suis content d'être là tu vois
franchement je kiffe être avec vous je
regrette pas du tout cette idée des 35
heures je me sens bien nous sommes bien
dans ma tête je me sens bien dans mon
corps je me souviens d'un article
non mais franchement ça vaut kevin bravo
en tout cas bravo ça fait passer des 24
heures donc bravo à eux pour ce report
les dangers passionnés dans les douze
heures et 12 heures oui mais moi je vois
gros je vois déjà très gros lot mais joe
va
je vois très gros c'est ce qu'on me dit
souvent kevin mon chéri donc toi tu es
paraît que tu étais mentalist alors il
parait pas effectivement je suis
mentaliste c'est mon métier
donc ça consiste en quoi alors ça
consiste le mentalist c'est une
discipline qui regroupe plusieurs arts
de la psychologie et de la maîtrise de
l'esprit humain
you may qui s'en servent à but médical y
en a qui s'en servent à but
spectaculaire moi j'ai un spectacle
d'artistes me produis empreinte
mentalist
il paraît que tu as été troisième
magicien préféré des français en 2016
exactement c'est tombé ya pas longtemps
et je vois que tu es bien informé quand
même secte est qualifié au nostradamus
d'or en 2018 c'est un concours européen
de mentalisme exactement donc voilà
nostradamus de l'irak et me dois de 2000
euros j'ai répété losail au gallon voile
alors si tu le si tu le croises tu
pourra lui dire mon chéri tu peux faire
des tours avec des cartes donc en fait
tu nous appeler comme ça pour vois là
pour nous faire un petit truc
alors en fait je vais te montrer un
record aussi puisque toi après un bond
record je vais tenter d'en bas train
avec toi si tu veux bien
en fait je vais faire une expérience qui
est interactive c'est à dire que tu vas
participer que les personnes qui sont
sur le plateau avec toi vont participer
mais surtout et des spectateurs qui sont
chez eux sur leur canapé vont aussi
participer d'accord donc tout le monde a
participé d'accord absolument pas m'ont
alors dit nous ce qu'on doit faire
alors avant de commencer avant de faire
cette expérience gerland faire une avec
toi c'est une expérience que j'ai appelé
alors pense quoi pas besoin d un
original t'adore la ford c'est raide
alors j'ai pas si tu me vois à l'écran
j'ai dans les mains un paquet de cartes
ou simple et qui accentue le crois pas
je le vois je vais te demande et cyril
dans ma tête et uniquement dans ta tête
de penser à une carter pas un as un roi
pas une dame tout le monde l'ait choisi
un set non plus une perte quelconque
maintenant spontanément base est donc en
train de me dire que je dois dire deux
trois quatre cinq six maintenant
spontanément une carte n'importe quel
jeu la carte plus c'est à dire par
exemple voilà d'accord c'est bon là si
dur là bas c'est bon alors à un pétard
tu penses est ce que tu peux dire vote
je ne voudrais pas le 9 de carreau le 9
de carreau vraiment intéressant on peut
on peut saluer carolina au passage bien
sûr ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est que dans ce package d une seule
carte à l'envers et une seule
alors je vais essayer de montrer je vais
l'ouvrir tout doucement je suis bien en
face je vais l'ouvrir tout doucement et
on peut voir que dans ce paquet alors je
vais le faire doucement on a une seule
carte à l'envers
et ouais c'est vrai qu'elle est cette
seule carte n'est pas finie stérile tu
aller encore un petit peu plus loin je
me suis permis de faire une prédiction
cet après midi à 14 heures quand on
émission a commencé j'ai fais une
prédiction
je vais sur ma page facebook et j'ai
publié une photo une seule alors je vais
pas montré alors j'ai imprimé la page
facebook pour ceux qui ont pré facebook
a lancé pour cheikh loin avec nous
d'ailleurs demain soir gérard louvin
battu froid pour moi c'est sincère alors
j'ai ma page facebook vous pouvez vous
connecter en direct pour vérifier c'est
interactif vous pouvez vous connecter
sur ma page facebook en tapant le cas
iqu et j'ai publié tout à l'heure cette
photo alors tu vas me dire tu connais
cette photo c'est une photo de pau a
priori elle est tout à fait normal mais
il est quelques signaux qui devrait
parler par exemple si tu regardes bien
j'étais mis un bouquet de fleurs dans
les mains et c'est bizarre mais si tu
comptes n'est rose tu vois qu'il ya
exactement neuf roses exactement comme
la carte à laquelle tu vas pensait alors
on peut aller plus loin aussi si tu
regardes bien ici dans la date le b 2
octobre en fait c'est un oeuf les
modifier et ça c'est aussi un signe tu
peux aussi voir que dans les cartes mais
j'avais mis si on a une femme un valet
indice est à 8
ce qui signifie qu'il manque le neuf il
ya aussi d'autres signes comme le fait
que dans touche pas à mon poste leo de
mon post était devenu des neuf alors
jusque là tu vas me dire super
prédictions j'avais prédit que tu parles
du 9 mai s'il est encore plus troublant
risque si on regarde bien le logo de
touche pas à mon poste c'est pas moi qui
l'aï inventé et pourtant c'est marrant
mais si tu prends le touche pas et en
noir
ça fait neuf lettres et si tu prends le
mon poste ça fait aussi neuf lettres ce
qui aussi tranche iris et que b de baba
il est en bleu et que c'est la neuvième
lettre du titre de l'émission
et là où je t'ai fait plaisir et ça va
te rappeler ton enfance j'étais mis dans
la poche une carte panini je sais pas si
tu laboures j'adore ouais ouais c'est
ton équipe préférée je sais qu'on n'est
pas nombreux et le savoir mais c'est
l'équipe du pakistan
oui c'est un joueur
et si le numéro 9 et tu peux vérifier
j'ai galéré approuvé la forme c'est bien
le numéro 9 aujourd'hui elle est juste
très bon ok bravo frérot est uv à nous
voir quand tu veux sur le plateau abbas
et plus toi quand tu veux mais quand
dans grand plaisir de tous ah non tu
habites uk ns
j'habite à grenoble je viens de la même
ville que il s'appelle louis dubost
irene prévue mais c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave je t'aime quand même on est
arrivé avec kevin tu as été formidable
oui mais les spectateurs
c'est pas parce que tu en penses
bah oui tu vas nous faire le truc à moi
et m'a dit vas-y tu as raison j'ai envie
celle qui arrive c'est ça oui énorme il
est là il est beau il est magnifique
il est là il est magnifique c'est très
simple écoutez bien les consignes je
vais vous montrer six cartes et tous les
quatre sur le plateau vous allez choisir
une carte est chez vous les
téléspectateurs aussi vous allez choisir
une carte
alors je vous montrais six cartes
concentrez-vous bien sûr le signora dmd
vallée des rois d'accord concentrez-vous
bien sûr la carte
je vais vous l'âme en pré attention ça
va aller très vite alors choisissez une
carte de choisir une carte là dedans moi
aussi dans votre tête bien sûr et moi
aussi tout le monde absolument tout le
monde même les gens chez eux et moi bien
sûr aussi mais moi aussi
oui mais bon voilà maintenant que s'est
choisi regardez bien ce que je vais
faire je vais simplement penser que la
carte à laquelle vous avez pensé cette
paix celle ci je vais simplement retiré
une et maintenant je vais vous
remonterez cet art si jamais et
seulement si jamais la carte à laquelle
vous pensiez a disparu je vais vous
demander de lever la main non c'est
dingue mais c'est tout le monde avait
bien choisi sa fille aurait donné cher
caustique et alors tu peux revoir la
vidéo si tu veux te faire voir le replay
les cartes ne bougent pas ils sont pas
mal mais j'ai pris des très grands
partent exprès mais mettez les mêmes
cartes à leur guise et les mêmes alors
tu peux repasser en arrière si tu veux
on se regarde le replay ensemble si tu
veux prêt demain soir tranquille c'est
incroyable et promis de faire sur le
plateau et au moins n'aura pas ben bravo
mon chéri bah franchement et kevin
après on t'embrasse fort tu viens de
voir si tu veux mon kevin s'allume ou
des bijoux
ça lui a pris à lui montrer comment ça
va très bien mais êtes vous bah ouais
ouais ouais c'est vrai il a fait quoi me
bats je renonce coûte mais j'ai bombay
mais là bas on est en voiture on arriver
plus vite est bizarre c'est de souhaiter
mouillé j'ai fait c'est vrai que le sol
est mou défaut de faire très graves sur
les souliers jouer vite ça revient en
plus très très fort on a examiné qui est
avec nous qui veut poser une question à
claude alexis notre voyant s'allume
avoue japonais j'avoue nous ça vous
avoue xavier niche
oui oui bien sûr alors on se tutoie
alors maintenant comment il va grand fou
tu habites hoop annonce hui nancy
j'adore la ville de michel platini
autres platoche ouais ouais ça colle de
moselle taquet l'accroché riz 24 ans 24
ans tu fais quoi dans la vie
je suis chronique érosion sur une petite
radio locale en hausse à la super ça se
passe bien on serait les options tout
smt et ça va tout le temps à mon chéri
bas merci mais ça coûte
merci d'être là en tout cas tu es
vraiment un amour alors tu vas être lu
tous félicité a reçue depuis 14h30 hier
de ouf batin à mon chéri tu vois je
viens de voir quand tu veux ça nous fera
plaisir d'accord tu me dis voilà je veux
du qu'est ce qui se passe avec une meuf
tesson meuf non à laquelle
elle a quel âge elle elle travaille
demain ben encore en étude
d'accord c'est quoi comme étude est bon
les un gros bisou elle fait de domont
les prévisions toi tu voulais adresser à
monsieur alexis claude alexis notre
voyons qui a fait des prédictions
exceptionnel cet après midi je tiens à
le dire à l'oreille monsieur monsieur à
un niveau bravo mon claude lavoie non
s'il y avait du public autour applaudi
et l'on vous laisse calme un petit peu
parce qu'il est quand même il est quand
même voilà il est quand même bientôt 3
heures du mat la loi de tout lâcher
alors quelle est ta question pour claude
alexis mons japonais bas du cou qui vont
en moi un avenir
alors je vais te le dire moi comme ça je
te dirai oui maintenant ses exams rooney
qui te poses pas comme de l'ordre wacom
de lanvaux c'est quoi ton modèle c qui
franchement bats toi non quand même en
amour mais bon mieux non aujourd'hui ce
marché mettra sur le marché du poisson
il ya pas mieux sur le banc oui alors
claude mon chéri je sais que la survie
de naissance de ce jeune homme kafia sa
date de naissance alors qu'on a besoin
de ta date de naissance mots que ça
venait
et enfin pu me tuer alors 92 donc déjà
ce que je peux dire c'est que tu es né
le 18 mai c'est vrai que ça fait
excuse-moi casabona mais voilà 12 jours
18 juin ouais t'as reçu un appel ce jour
là va trop vite et d'autres ma gueule
mais franchement quelle année mon chéri
86 92 à l'étendard de dire des conneries
mais elle très sûre d'elle 86 il y avait
ni le 8000 aussi ses quatre ans elle
s'est même pas alors claude alors au
niveau de deux visuels
honnêtement non maintenant tu vois tu
venu dès lors il dit la vérité mais
j'adore parce que toi tu dis toujours la
vérité
au niveau de l'audio
je peux me tromper attention tous le
monde de la radio oui ça y est la
possibilité de pouvoir refusant l'audio
que dans le visuel
comment oui dans l'audio plus dans le
dio pas donné mais vous resterez pas sur
un an 6 know that way
non vous ne restez pas là où je vous
changer de lieu
tout là-haut et vous changer de
département également vous partez plus
sur une est visible et qu'il serait
beaucoup plus importante on d'accord du
nom mon chéri si les résultats qui vont
faire ils vont avoir besoin de
changement bah oui tu vois une gamine en
mai est donc donc plus dans la radio
mais pas la nana plus d'un à radio les
prix très beau parcours un très beau
parcours hexagone est très bon parcours
au shérif par contre sera également x
qui ne voient pas forcément cette
domaine de l'écriture d'accord sûr que
tu écrives plus on cherche auxquels pôle
nature ne l'est plus un domaine de
l'écriture qui ressort des mines de
radio d'accord donc l'écriture est pour
cam à venir aux côtés de baba quoi
pourquoi mon chéri je vais peut-être je
pensais le delta j'apprends de la radio
un jour un ouais pas dans les dix
prochaines années mais peut-être un jour
d'après la radio tu portes avant
chroniqueur bas bien sûr sans rivaux les
normes et mon chéri vient nous voir un
jour que je te rencontre d'accord en
fait la rue mais je viens de te revoir
bah voilà tout comme xavier en tout cas
merci nous avoir rappelé et tu lâches
rien mon chéri tu restes toi même si je
peux donner un conseil et voilà c'est
pas de copier les autres le soin que
travers le mois il y as très bien
j'aimerais avoir une photo xavier
pouvoir parce que je suis sûr que je me
rappelle de lui sur twitter c'est xavier
pilawa comment ça va bouger mais je sais
je le connais très bien et xavier
mercier mon chéri que c'est pour tous
tes messages c'est vraiment un amour non
mais je te le dirai de rien parce que je
sais que je sais que tu sais pas ce que
tu peux le voir
joli tous les messages de tous les gens
qui me laisse des de tous les tweets
hausse on a presque 4 millions de
followers maintenant et xavier je veux
être invitée pour les 4 millions
eh bien bon les 4 millions va faire une
énorme fête mon chéri et bien sûr que tu
seras invité je vous jure je connais
pratiquement tous les noms des gars donc
et xavier je sais qu'il est très actif
et un amour mon chéri merci d'être
toujours présent sur twitter avec moi tu
es vraiment un amour sant est vraiment
kiffé je te fais un gros bisou mais
xavier barbaro bisous un bon courage
montana bon vous aviez tu nous suit
jusqu'à demain va dormir un peu plus
rien je voudrais pas que tu passe l'armé
à gauche battement tu as une belle
carrière devant toi oui bonjour il
s'enferre le fayot faut reconnaître que
vous mettez le pied à l'étrier à
beaucoup de personnes deux jeunes gens
qui vous croyez vous les aidez beaucoup
dans le métier a progressé à se lancer
et c'est dans ces vrais c pa du fayotage
d'un coup franc suivant parce que non
mais on a eu la chance nous d'avoir des
gens qui nous donne notre chance voilà
il ya plein de jeunes qui ont du talent
je vois sur twitter il ya des mecs qui
sortent des vannes mais incroyable et
voilà c'est pas que je connais les gars
et xavier c'est un gars qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de talent et je lui fais un
énorme bisou il est très actif en tout
cas sur twitter allez on va voir à il ya
quelqu'un la porte pour moi c'est qui
c'est qui citations la police non c'est
vrai c'est la politique par amants n'ont
donc fait rentrer fait rentrer gardien
no 1
après j'aimerais bien avoir joris au
téléphone de lyon qui voudrait avoir des
idées d'endroits insolites pour faire
l'amour voilà les deux à leur prose ou
en vers de temps puisque déjà t'as pas
vu tout à l'heure mais quand il a parlé
du seuil mouillé sol mouillé de sa moto
il me regarde et me fais un truc avec
des sourds sinon bon t'es super mal non
c'est vrai ah ouais je te jure ça peut
être votre style donc aux mets mes coups
mais c'est énorme que tu fais là mon
chéri c'est assez magique devant le
petit bisou mais je te donnais des
forces serait un amour celui-ci maire
simon bg d'éclat merci je ne sens pas là
c'est qu'on était à deux doigts de pécho
là il c'est la tuile
non mais je suis hyper contente de voir
c'est vrai mais j'ai 13 ans franchement
qu'est vraiment un amour d'être là
vraiment un bon jour à tout va que tu es
tu veux pas je m'assieds l'a peut-être
ses murs non mais toi tu es avec moi par
là mais pas côté le toit côté de rose
hill et et mercy mais je suis content de
te voir tient alors justement va voir
joris au téléphone dans un instant et
joris il aimerait avoir des idées
d'endroits insolites pour faire l'amour
est ce que vous auriez vous ou es ce que
vous avez fait on va pas demander à
claude un bien entendu mais vous
jean-michel l'endroit le plus insolite
le plus un par l'avion jeudi l'avion la
vision
froid l'avion trois fois trois fois pas
sur la même ligne
regardez il ya un pote à moi qui viens
de voir john mamann mon chien sur mes
locaux toi mon job commentant la mode
enfin consommer en partouze et sincère
d'un front chaud qui cite on va rigoler
attend vas-y toi c'est moi notre jeune
talent exceptionnel un job tiens un
autre compositeur je vous lis fait
partie pour moi et je te le dis mon dieu
parce que tu es mon pote fait partie du
top quatre top-5 conseil avait vraiment
aux quatre c'est un bateau qui est
nouveau pour moi top 3 je pense à 3
ouais je signale au mondial écoute super
g des mondiaux j'ai un petit truc pour
toi d'ailleurs préféré jeter en studio
avec vita non j'adore
elle est un peu en mode race rats non
puisque là c'est pas avait encore me
faire des chansons d'amour voulait faire
d'ohb tempo elle un peu je vais la
ramener tu vas un peu maladroit mallet a
dit à l'ats
mais on peut la rigueur tu es magnifique
assieds-toi ses droits merci confiance
et savais que je quitte cette équation
sans déconner un très bon ça va être
sympa ça va vite on verra john n'avait
pas elle pouvait pas nous change un
petit truc là qu'on fasse un petit ils
ont parlé des endroits insolites pour
faire l'amour
voyez vous pas parce que hp ya joris en
ligne qui est avec nous parle mal a dit
quoi je suis resté à côté de la bonne
personne c'est que je pense tout le
temps
nauru partout des q2 or si la nuit
plutôt les mecs qui disent athées je me
vois tout le temps non en fait c'est
parce qu'il est tout le temps aller lui
il est tout le temps la vita canton n'a
dit un endroit insolite pour faire
l'amour vous avez votre micro vous avez
dit ça ça me parle non g27 parle
d'accord pourquoi je sais que l'on doit
le plus insolite
ouais c'est pas lui c'est l'avion il a
fait trois fois l'avion c'est l'avion
c'est top c'est pas mal à vos caroline
bout moi je dirais le hammam ah ouais
ouais ouais la lame s'est fait pas trop
chaud et bien justement s'il fait sur du
rush est un pareil sans rigoler même
même ton zisis eu tellement tu rentres
avec une merguez sort avec un mikado
frère
du coup ça glisse ça toujours été avec
des mecs là comme d'habitude ça mathieu
c'est quoi le bras solides vous ayez
fait l'amour mais ce qu'ils font en fait
c'est quand elle interdit quand on veut
on peut se faire choper jaffe la rue
j'ai déjà fait le train la rue la rue
dans la rue vraiment la rue comme ça
dans la rue bah il y avait au marché
dans la rue il était un peu tard mais
pas tant que ça à minuit donc c'est
comme une rue passante il y avait
quelques travaux et une palissade
on a fait ça derrière donc à tout moment
pouvait surgir
j'ai déjà fait la plage me suis fait
gauler par le jeune aurait été au club
med
pardon pour les marques ont été sur la
plage et le vigile est arrivé il a ma
soeur c'est comme ça il est anormal vais
commencer ridicule tata le sexe à l'air
et twitter comme ça j'étais tout avec
miss l'ipcum ça aurait fait le train
j'ai fait les boîtes de nuit j'ai fait
mon chéri faudra une émission on a on à
jour ils sont ligne qui nous happe et il
a 21 ans et habite lyon
joris à lui c'est pas une belle surprise
john mamann évita qui viennent nous voir
comme ça il sortit de suite c'est
magnifique et j'adore aussi le single il
est fou ou la palabre l'apa single de
vintage ou qu'on fasse un petit kiff
comme ça john john évita vous
enregistrer qu ensemble c'est quoi vous
allez faire un petit tour en fait ceux
qui composent quasiment tout mon album
comme la chanson way est moche mais il
me fait des folies vraiment un génie
je vous dis la soprano il ya lui il ya
des gars ont parlé de black est aussi
tout à l'heure il ya une génération là
de souffler mais comme ces lectures mois
on arrive dans l'équipement simple et
mme brault quoi voilà nom et est là
c'est qu'on sait quoi les chansons
séjour que le style d'écouter un peu de
tout on a fait un duo 6 ans tous les
deux tous les deux badiou généralement
ces deux c'est vrai quoi c'est quoi le
duo pape avant un petit truc un dieu
s'appelle comme la première fois ça les
dérange là mais pas quoi assaillants bah
ouais les kits ambiance des surmas je
kiffe grave je kiffe double aussi je
sois tu as qui fort de chanteurs moi tu
vois en fait t'as vu c'est pas si
vraiment je m'embrouille avec tous les
animateurs je kiffe tous les chanteurs
et des sportifs est ce qu on est toutes
les paroles en bresse
bezos mes oreilles prison club et yul
sur google a l'habitude et ils sont pas
les seuls avec vitaa convaincront la sto
joris est avec nous c'est un homme aux
jo bats toi bats pas tu vas payer
non ça va tu fais quoi dans la vie je
travaille dans prêt-à-porter a vu le
prêt-à-porter féminin masculin qui a dit
quoi
chez jules la figure non c'est pas vrai
et maxi que j'achète souvent des trucs
chez jules ah ouais c'est pas chercheurs
et parlant lyon alors pas de problème
mais si je passe sur lyon moi j'aimerai
te voir tu en es où toi sentimentalement
bah écoutes je suis célibataire c'est
pour ça j'aimerais mettre un petit peu
de piment
un petit peu de piment dans ma vie dans
ces portages aimerait tant les verts
vers l'est du secteur michel hamm et
veut faire il veut faire des trucs tout
seul dans les yeux instruite en fait il
est célibataire n'ont rencontré une
fille ya des endroits où aller pour
rencontrer une rencontre et je restais
avec son amoureuse non non non pas du
tout alors c est gratuit
si vous pouvez lui proposer quelques
noms mais ouais c'est avec les sites
internet maintenant et à attin d'heure
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable tous les
réseaux sociaux facebook où tous les
réseaux sociaux c'est que ça maintenant
c'est que décideront entre tes sur les
réseaux cérébraux ou pas joris était sur
un site de rencontres west indoor ouais
alors avec pas ou feint pas ouvrir pas
ouf je voulais savoir surtout si
jean-michel il avait des endroits un peu
à venir ouais mais jules a dû faire un
petit peu de partout mais sur wii je
suis pas lione moi attendions mais si
vous avez payé chemin vous avez vous
trimballez votre connell partout non
vitaa nyonnaise alors je suis pas dans
le même terroriste et avec une mafia
n'ya pas longtemps ou pas du tout ouais
c'est une mafia pas longtemps après
c'était fini
donc là c'est pour ça je m'amuse un peu
court en soirée ému si jamais je compte
créer une fille ils vont bien faire
l'amour droit solide alors partagé en
particulier via l'avion mais bon ça
coûte cher il faut voyager
il a fait ça sur la plage il a fait ça
dans la rue lui les plus beaux et les
plus bon marché au niveau du sexe rose
hill on n'a pas su notre échappée en
fait je me suis dit c'est arrêté avant
non non non non non c'était il ya
quelques années quand même un des eaux
c'était sur un sur un parking de poids
lourds sur le capot d'une d'une grosse
berline
non c'est pas vrai ah ouais si et huawei
nuit mais je me suis dit que les routes
il avait dû quand même entendre un petit
peu il avait dû qui fait quoi et alors
il avait un beau pot d'échappement les
verbund pour des chutes à dix c'était
quoi et sur le capot sous le capot elle
a pas l'air classe elle est chaude et je
t'ai dit il ya quelques années ses
membres à se déguiser bissau nisme était
4 heures du matin on a essayé de pas
faire de bruit
voilà vous avez essayé de pas faire de
bruit aussi ça c'est un truc qui
n'arrivera jamais que jean michel
labaeye ça arrive pas ah bah ça je sais
c'est le problème parce qu'on a trouvé
la chanson de avec vitaa et jule ou bien
on attend demain matin cette arrivée va
attendre demain pour la voir qu'est ce
qui aboutirait faut attendre demain pour
voir la photo avec larry je pense mon
chéri joris bah écoute des time of tu
nous dis ouais savoir ce que j'espère
une paix qui cassent ou pas bien sûr
j'ai fait rien d'efficace société a à
mes potes et si possible d'avoir un
petit cadeau même le nouvel album de
soprano ce que tu appelles nouvel album
de soprano et je rajoute je rajoute on
rajoute on rajoute le prochain album
après album qui arrive déjà avec
notamment le déballer john babas
d'accord il s'appelait comment la barre
je suis je sais pas quand je suis en
plein dedans
d'accord résister nous avions laissé
trouver le type de tournoi forming ça
rigolait au nombre elles sont bien là
des discussions j'ai un peu peur avoue
reichmann alors pas du tout revanchard
les élites on va on va changer on va
changer de on va changer de thème les
chéris vita et john vous avez nous
raconter l'album on va essayer de
trouver le titre
du prochain album de joanna si on peut
le trouver ce soir ça serait faux vous
nous proposez des trucs sur twitter
hashtag album vita vital raconte moitié
peu jones cas dans l'album avec vitaa et
on va essayer de trouver alors écoutez
un peu moins d'amour qu'avant un peu
moins d'amour ouais ça l énerve veut pas
d'accord rester sur l'amour dans ça
bouge beaucoup et beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de produits l'appelle pas
l'amour en moi l'amour en à l'amour en
moi l'amour en moins est ce que c'est un
peu auto bio il ya pas mal de tokyo à
l'arrivée avec bébé vite à ta vie a pas
mal par contre on dirait un restaurant
japonais au 22 mois est ce qu'elle est
trompettes et tambours n'ont aucune
chance à brute au sens de seront tambour
ni trompette très bon n'écoutez pas lu
mon frère il a tant donné
lui voulait couper pour l'album mon
frère que je sais c'est une blague
cassou marchessault ouais mais est déjà
et l'orthophoniste faudra y est retourné
lundi prochain tous les noms mais si moi
j'ai envie qu'on trouve le titre de
l'album
vous avez une idée claude a look et
alexis c'est notre voyant un accord
merci on le laisse réfléchir on le
retrouve vite adam comme état d'âme tu
vas tu as déjà vite a donc huit à damas
et match est pour l'instant qui veut
dire que ta vie c'est pas mal non
franchement vers la vie alors il valait
de ta vie c'est très fort aimait tahawy
ouais mais il est fort j'aime beaucoup
ma vie tu as tu crois pas que tu vas
faire ça sans déconner tu sais que c'est
fort c'est malin je suis ta job écoute
ta vie tu vois c'est pas comment bientôt
non pas parce que cet avis on a
tellement entendu ta vie que tu as à vis
à vis à vis ta vie
mais ce qui est dur c'est qu'il faut une
chanson qui en font un titre qui est
qui porte en raison d'un des titres de
la loi alors de fixer aujourd'hui c'est
l'espagnol aujourd'hui c'est le chilien
s'est créé quelques quêtes etc et non
mais c'est vrai capital il ya quoi c'est
quoi les titres déjà qu'on a en stock la
prendre l'air prendre l'air d'accord il
ya ça les dérange c'est hélas les
dérange pas mal il ya bien venu à paris
qu'est le single du moment non j'aime
pas je vous dis la vérité ta moder
bienvenue à paris ça fait et c ie flavie
côté 1,9 c est honda on a en tout et on
a vitamine c dans mes favorites mais non
mais arrêtez avec vitaya vitalité c'est
naze non franchement tellement tu as
tout bas ont procédé il est plutôt sont
les embrasse quand même parce qu'il est
temps mais seriez 3 heures du matin les
gars se donne un mal de chien mais je
veux dire pour l'instant on a tous donné
des idées de merde à part mathieu de
l'embauché
alors il ya quoi comme autre site pour
l'instant ça les dérange c'est pas mal
on tique dalle npn ou pitié peine ou
paitier duroueix mais ça fait
dostoïevski ouais j'aime pas à nice y'a
quoi l'autre qu'est ce qu'ils savent
faire pénis mais pitié benzema allait
bien jusqu ici j'habite à 20 bornes je
fais 20 banques pour venir ici et marées
fait les arrêts clés en fait moi je
reste ici
d'accord mais je les connais
alors c'est le mot de la fin nominé
terrible vita pour l'instant j'aime bien
ou vittavi où ça les dérange ça les
dérange c'est très bon
j'aime bien le titre d'album ça les
dérangements moi je moi je vote ça les
dérange quittons nous sur twitter si
vous menacez sans rire j'aime bien le
abrita on va on va faire une perte du
genre salut salut vie par un salut à
l'orbiteur vers nous voir pour tout
nouvel album ça les dérange savent sur
quoi que rappeler cet album ça dérange
écoute j'ai l'impression un peu de
peut-être celle qui est là depuis un
moment et qui tu vois tu déranges voilà
ça que je dérange et ce que je reviens
est ce que justement je les dérange je
ne le dérange pas voilà mais bon je
trouve que eh non la marque
c'est ce qu'il faut c'est ça les dérange
pour moi franchement je donne le titre
et bombarde gagné donc au sens où ils
iront de signer je vous jure que pour de
vrai il faut que ton prochain album
s'appelle fallait des anges ita et coûte
peut-être que c'est hyper fort moi
j'adore reçoit en octobre oui merci
thomas il a vu un truc comme excuse moi
faut que je te passe côté mena est-ce
qu'il embarquait le prochain album de
vitaa
oui il va marcher maintenant je vois
quand même travailler sur un titre qui
est déjà fait mais que vous êtes en
train de modifier sa sale boulot
vraiment un titre qui lui tient qui
tient à coeur à m
yahia aime aussi méric et un mot qu'elle
veut absolument lever modifié dedans
c'est quoi vraiment c'est un peu le
problème sur tous les types c'est à dire
que c'est jamais fini en fait sermonner
on vient pas nous mettre la pression du
pain c'est fini entre éléments s'arrête
jamais fait ça mais bon et cloud et
claude depuis cet après midi est très
fort ils ont comme dit l avoir un enfant
oui c'est vrai franchement je vois pas
d'où tu as vu que j'allais avoir un
enfant 4 en jetpack est normal on met un
enfant mon frère il va naître il va
avoir 18 piges mais bon je vois pas ben
non mais vraiment a vu un enfant qui va
arriver où kate jack est déjà au cours
qui vint mais il est et rhône a fait le
dos ou pas soit ils ont posé une
solution ouais j'ai couché ou pas donc
l'autre sans déconner c'est à dire qu'il
est en route là il vient d'hériter donc
il me fait peur n'en sais pas si en 2016
c'est plus quelque chose qui reçoivent
2010 elle devra adaptation wii en 2010
c'est parce que par hasard claude pas
une adoption
c'est pas forcément un enfant qui a été
conçue ça peut être assez plat forcément
un enfant qu était un enfant qui est un
enfant qui arrive chez vous c'est pas
pour halloween qui va venir je cherchais
des bonbons et il a 22 ans va arriver et
papa il me rappelle le moi c'était voilà
non mais et claude il dit pas de bêtise
donc je vous le dis très prochainement
si vous êtes un enfant si vous voulez
tellement d'abord sachez le jeu vous
ouvrez un grand plaisir à mes jolis noms
mais vous ne savez pas quoi où ça veut
dire oui qu'en 2017
toi et moi bon allez on va adopter ont
parqué choisir les bécasses en hammam et
700 ramènera pas besoin dans la personne
n'est dans la personne et de visu en
face de lui claude peut donner un
pronostic vital
voilà je vous dis claude je vous le dis
on a fait les gars on a fait 13 heures
d'antenne ça y est il est 3h du matin
donc il ya treize mille euros pour
l'association c'est que du bonheur
c'est bon pas les maigres et les mecs
qui sont fracasse mais qui va équiper
ils ont trouvé toutes les chansons sur
place chanson ou rouler avec vitaa et
jule on va la trouver cette chanson m'a
écouté tout l'album de doula jundollah
on l'a on n'a pas aller on a on l'a dit
mais vous reste comme tu peux tu nous es
là dès que vous êtes fatigués vous allez
tous à 100 moi je vais pas tarder à me
coucher
non mais je dors bien jeu restera
longtemps mais d'accord je sais pas on
va boire on est bien là et bien là
merci en tout cas évita je vous le dis
vous êtes de plus en plus belle c'est
très gentil
non mais vraiment et je ne dis pas ça
tout le monde non c'est pas parce que
moi je dis souvent la vérité il faut
appeler un chat
ça va ça se passe bien avec votre mari
très bien comment elle est heureuse elle
un bon pas aller comme ça mais c'est un
le mariage c'est un mois j'ai c'est un
métier de tous les jours c'est pas comme
ça en fait c'est vrai c'est un travail
j'attends c'est mon groupe préféré de
tous les couples qui n'ont mené que
c'est maintenant que vous êtes avec
votre mec sept ans il faut que dans un
cas pareil
ouais il paraît sept ans ça veut rien
dire la jetée sept ans jusqu'au 1er août
avec les meufs
écoute je suis séparé depuis pas
longtemps puisque tu étais que je dois
mieux c'est non non ah oui avec
l'ancienne équipe a repris
non pas du tout attends tu va embaucher
l'ancien cet ange et le bbc a sauté oui
l'enfant fait gaffe parce qu'il ya un
autre enfant qui volera pas tabou
reprofilage et une nouvelle qui en
régissent qua non à la voile et la voilà
en fait un joli cadeau souvenir
oui je croyais que j'étais un ami
soutien de la présente pas allez dites
est arrivé trop vite arrivé trop tard
fait une passe avec nous on travaille
pas et que noël m'a accompagné c'est un
amour son économie ou pas je te sens
love écoute ça fait combien de temps que
tu as été ça fait quelques mois
combien un mois et demi de tournée avec
sera donné mon nom avec avec ça va
pendant un mois et demi sans déconner
c'est le kiff parce que c'est quand tu
peux encore à parler à tes potes sont
les sous les dents mais c'est vrai exact
franchement c'est bon mais où ne pas en
parler ça te dérange même pas ne pas en
parler parce que tu kiffes mais en vrai
en vrai parce que nous les mecs on va
pas se mentir
le premier truc qu'on fait quand on
pêche ou une meuf
on est en train de la pécho franchement
on est en train de la galoche on pense
qu'à une chose c'est quand on va appeler
nos potes pour dire ça y est je suis
avec ma nouvelle mais ça y est les
groupes ah ouais c'est vrai après ça
dépend bon lui c'est un problème c'est
que si la paix tout le monde il aura
plus de la meuf surtout en fin de temps
avant de bien on dirait non mais en
attendant il y a que nous qui les qui
font tout ce à quoi on veut pas raconter
c'est un plaisir tout vous mathieu vous
raconter à vos potes quand vous pilotez
une meuf ou encore caen voilà
ouais sinon je recommanderais beaucoup
quand vous croisez le faire je raconte
non mais je suis moi je suis en plus
d'un succès comme jean-michel très là il
est tard on peut le dire moi je très bon
camarade c'est à dire que si c'est une
de 6 et un bon coup on va dire la vérité
est vrai que j'ai pas de sentiment je
fis le pote
non c'est vrai moi je file et d'auto
pomme bah oui bah oui moi moi moi même
jean michel maire est ce que moi je suis
extrêmement droit et jean michel maire
le nombre de passes décisives que je lui
ai fait dans l'émission c'est raviolis
et moi reprise de volée boom lucarne
on va lui le problème c'est que c'est le
ibrahimovic du sexe vous dérange pas
trop ce qu'est ce qu'on vous dit tout
quoi vous vous dites pas vous dit à vos
copines quand vous chope nous je crois
qu'on parle vraiment de l'attargette
nous on fantasme qu'on est là il va
osciller comme ça qu'est ce que tu
fraises d'été à ma place etc
on aura de voir de quoi elle est fille
rapidement quand je suis chauffeur je me
fais un vrai qui fait quoi et k3 4,9 qui
sont dans téléfoot
je me régale et je sais que moi aussi
quand ma main ça va y aller va faire
pareil l'appareil quoi m'angoisse un peu
c'est vrai ou 40 et trucs nous dit voilà
je suis chanteuse sur ce mec a
complètement moi j'adore dhr en fait
imaginez donc je fantasme le truc
évidemment je demande l'avis de toutes
les copines et après voilà je fais mon
je fais moi je fais mon affaire
mais c'est vrai qu'on parle lâchement de
cul entre autres filles puisque c'est
devenu vraiment les espèces de soirée
fillon vous aimez ou appréciez le mec
avant qu'il se passe quelque chose c'est
sympa mais par contre quand ça a
commencé à aller mal et que vous taillez
c'est d'une violence en parler de plus
le faire les meufs les boeufs façon très
violente à québec rose il ya un petit
cocktail là pour moi parce que si vous
étiez naturopathe on m'a dit que vous
aviez préparé un cocktail est bon il est
fusillé en coulisses et au cdja quoi
dans ce cocktail il est au frigo faire
quoi il ya de la pomme il y a des
mais pas que la saillie à quoi une
petite bête on trouve au brésil c'est un
antioxydant en antioxydants c'est plein
de vitamines et hébron pour me donner sa
propre rue tenir pour tenir bon alors
est ce que je ferai ce qu'il vaudrait
pas mieux pas que je prenne vers 5h du
mat tu la sens que rien d'un petit choc
maintenant et puis alors au petit
château non non à 55 ans mais qu'est ce
qu'ils en pensent bah oui parce que si
ça réveille maintenant
ben non moi ce qui me fascine ouais
vraiment chez vous naturopathe ce gars
il fait rien il a il met pas une
criminelle mais s'accroche il a pas le
début d'une ride il rien il a une peau
de 18 ans y'a rien il n'y a pas une ride
ici c'est comme comment tu fais toi
c'est pas incroyable mais non même pas
mais non mais sans révéler la télé ça
sera le début d'une crème c'est parce
qu'une onde pour tous quelle crème qui
sont vendus merci nice mais c'est fou
comment comment tu fait de ton secret
beauté jeu très tôt tu sais ouais je ne
sors jamais c'est vrai je ne suis pas il
fait pas je ne me drogue pas une idée du
ca apparemment il ne fallait pas
d'influx non mais voilà pour la santé de
dérobade non mais c'est vrai que moi et
jean-michel pourra témoigner je n'ai
jamais vu de ma vie j'ai jamais fumé je
me suis jamais drogué jamais même pas un
joint jamais fumé un joint et le café à
miami non mais bon c'était jean bourassa
mais c'est bien c'est bon pas de café et
[Musique]
élémentaires c'est maintenant ça va
mieux maintenant ça revient à un moment
donné que c'est connu c'était tout le
temps tout le temps des sodas des sodas
des jamais d'eau les sodas dissuade
addition cdd somme avait appelé une fois
parce que j'étais fatigué à l'antenne
c'est un peu abusé sur les boîtes de
nuit jean-michel si tu peux tenir si tu
veux rester surtout parce que m'a
prévenu dit regarde une émission
quotidienne c'est comme un athlète de
haut niveau pas d'alcool du sport pas de
cigarette c'est une vie d'ascète voilà
si tu fais pas ça tu tiendras pas le
coût attendu
[Rires]
gars c'est l'inversé il est passionant
influence sur une longue carrière il
peut profiter
ouais mais j'ai envie vous faites une
saison magnifique pas ce genre pour
garder pour garder sur michel parfois
ils démarreront alors moi je la donnerai
l'heure michel jusqu'au jour où j'ai vu
les les cafetières comment il sera
demain soir
le premier est franchement ces médecins
c'est un battant comment il cahill et
c'est pour ça qu'on aime bien parce que
ce qu'on attend c'est un bâtard mêmes
motifs
non mais franchement c'est vrai j'ai
déjà mon fond on a exactement je vous
dis c'est un gars très très gentil comme
vous je vous d'abord les bâtards bons
fonds - non pas des bonbons dans les
pattes un bon fond enfin c'est ce qu'on
m'a dit vous savez vendre est vachement
gentil oui mais beaucoup d'autres non
mais rien quoi non mais franchement
alors je vous jure il y avait pas
d'arrière pensée
ah bon alors vraiment tout le monde me
dit tous vos excellents me disent que
vous avez un très bon fond norvégien qui
c'est à dire mathieu et voilà il reste
quand même un gentil mec c'est vrai ça
va claude vous êtes toujours avec nous
oui oui d'accord vous connaissiez john
mamann ou pas oui ça c'est un artiste
anglais et et oui lui et lui il est
parti pour 20 selon lui plus quand même
le jeudi à rennes un oui je sais que
c'est pas du tout mon émission et je
m'en excuse
alors c'est votre émission parce que
toutes les émissions sont vos émissions
mais touche à ton cul comme vous ferez
que je ferai le droit à une question 1
claude aco d'alexis ii le poignant et
vous oui sur vous oui alors j'aimerais
vous la poser maintenant oui et côte va
y répondre dans un instant à vous voulez
vous lui posez la question oui aller
parce que ça commence à me travailler
alors si c'est sur moi ça commence
maintenant
alors alors c'est pas sûr on ne sait pas
sur vous mais merci quand cette gamme
notamment ses pas sur vous et mis de
côté j'aimerais savoir claude pour de
vrai parce que là je ne rigole pas ça
commence à être pénible j'aimerais
savoir si oui ou non au moins en 2017
vous allez reprendre une émission déjà
eu le vendredi des poursuites claude
c'est quelqu'un qui est venu en ami
demain non j'aimerais savoir claude si
oui ou non je vais trouver quelqu'un
alors c'est que vous nous le dira et
dans un instant colmar ii mais vous
voulez qu'il peut acheter cette carte
c'est mieux j'aimais bien peu chez ses
pairs puisque là ça va être du cav est
du lourd vous vous lavez me poser une
question à poser vous à coude après
vient peut-être nous d'accord et vous
donne peut-être on peut voir si ça va
durer que la meuf qui est en régie ça
fait un mois et demi qu'elle est la plus
regardée au piège de rentrer tout seul
soit on va regarder ça va me donner une
réponse parce qu'on pose tous une
question à claude dans un instant
d'accord tous une question qui nous
tient à coeur
jean michel vous avez une question je
vous retrouvez une facilement invite à
carreaux rose hill mathieu on va
démarrer avec la question de mathieu on
va se retrouver dans un instant les
chéris on est avec vous c'est les 35
heures de baba et on continue jusqu'au
bout jusqu'à plus ou moins c'est ce que
tu veux toi
[Musique]